welcome everybody thanks so much for
joining me today my name is Brandon
Minnick and in this session we'll be
talking about an introduction to
serverless with AWS Lambda in C sharp
now I'm really excited to be here
talking about this with you today
because
I love serverless it's a topic that's
really near and dear to my heart so
hopefully you'll catch the bug that I
caught and love it too
but I'm actually a mobile app developer
I make IOS and Android apps in c-sharp
using xamarin and now.net Maui and I've
been publishing apps to the app store
for about the last seven years and when
I make my apps it's it's just me I'm
just the one guy I make these on nights
and weekends I do it for fun and if you
find my apps in the app store they're
totally free I don't charge any money
for them there's no in-app purchases
um and so when I needed a solution for
my back end because let's be honest
every every app needs a back end
um I needed something that would be easy
for me to maintain easy for me to
implement kind of something that set it
and forget it but also something
it's kind of cheap because I don't have
a lot of money off the zero dollar
profits that I'm making off these apps
and so that's when I found serverless so
we'll get into all the the goodies of
serverless and how it we can be an
individual developer like myself still
have a whole back end running in the
cloud and still be maintaining and
building and Publishing our apps all
thanks to serverless with AWS Lambda now
before we get going I want to point out
two links that you'll see at the bottom
of just about every slide today make
sure to take out your phone and grab a
picture of these Links at some point
because down here on the bottom right
this is a web page that I've made just
for this session today this contains
everything that we're about to cover so
you don't have to worry about memorizing
anything because if you go to that
webpage this is where you can find the
slides this is where you can find all
the code I have a end-to-end open source
sample that we're going to show off in
just a little bit and I've also included
a bunch of links to helpful resources
that I used when I was first learning
about server lists and Lambda and
c-sharp and all that fun stuff that
should be helpful for you too as well
plus these sessions are recorded So once
NDC posts the video on YouTube I'll make
sure to add the link there as well so
you can share it with your friends your
colleagues anybody else who couldn't
make it today but maybe is excited about
serverless as well
and then on the bottom left that is my
Twitter handle this is the best way to
get in contact with me so if you have
any questions we don't get a chance to
chat later on at the conference or if
you just ever want to chat about c-sharp
xamarin Maui serverless AWS whatever
feel free to come join in the
conversation
now
this is Introduction to serverless so
what what is serverless
um you know lately
serverless has kind of become this this
buzzword we probably hear it all the
time like serverless micro Services
um and if I'm being honest it's it's
kind of a weird term because
serverless implies that there's no
servers involved and that can't be true
you know the laws of physics state that
if we're going to run code that code's
got to run on a server right that code's
got to have a CPU it's got to have
memory and so nothing's actually truly
server less because then we wouldn't
have any code running so I found that a
better way to think of serverless is
actually
less server because yes your code will
still be running in the cloud on a
server but with serverless it means that
our our code isn't running 24 7. we
don't have a dedicated server given to
us by AWS that they're charging us every
second forward because we said you know
we need a certain amount of CPU cores
and this much memory and so if we had
that that wouldn't be serverless
serverless we basically are able to
publish our code to the cloud
and then whenever it's needed it spins
up that server and it runs so with
serverless we just have less server to
worry about less server to pay for our
monthly bills would be a little bit
cheaper less server to maintain so we
don't need a team of Engineers to make
sure that our server is up and running
all the time that our servers scaling
properly serverless takes away all of
those worries from us so that we can
just write our code
and run it in the cloud
now to really understand Services server
less let's go all the way back let's go
back to the days of on-premises now
I don't I don't think I've been around
that long I've been uh in the industry
for about 15 years but when I started
this was all we had there was there was
no Cloud when I started working my first
engineering job out of college uh the
company I worked at we just had a giant
data center you know the size of a
football pitch with just rows and rows
and rows and racks and every rack would
be filled with servers it'd be freezing
cold in there because servers generate a
lot of heat so you got to keep it really
cold it's really loud from all the
servers that are running and doing all
their computations and
I remember if I ever needed to do
something like let's say we were
building a new app well the first thing
I would have to do I would have to get a
server so back in the day with
on-premise I would first have to go to
procurement and say I need a new server
I needed to be this many CPUs this much
RAM and they go great the lead time is
six to eight weeks so about two months
later I would have a server appear on my
desk that once it would show up I'd grab
that server I'd walk it down to the data
center I'd find an open slot in a rack
rack and stack it bolt it in Connect up
all the cables and then once I could
finally turn it on well then I got to
install the operating system so we're
using Linux a lot at the time so install
the latest version of Linux make sure to
get all the security patches installed
from the it admins uh worked with the
networking team to make sure that we
have our firewalls in place and then I
can communicate with it and then finally
I could actually publish my code to the
server and we could run it
so with with on-premises it has a lot of
a lot of
well I don't say problems but it's
definitely a lot of questions a lot of
concerns you also need a real big team
of Engineers to maintain this stuff
because you know you need the engineers
like us who are going to be writing our
c-sharp code but you also need the team
of Engineers to maintain these servers
you need we need it admins to keep the
operating system up to date we need our
security administrators to make sure
that we're patching any vulnerabilities
we need our Network administrators to
make sure that our firewall is in place
and we're not going to get ddosed and
then on top of that we need physical
security that building had big barbed
wire fences all around it so nobody
could break in and damage the servers or
Worse steal our data and so big big
costs lots of stuff going on and we have
to have this huge team to manage all of
this just so I could build my app and on
top of that our workflows our timelines
we had to plan months years in advance
if we just wanted to publish a new app
because we had to plan for that
two-month lead time for the server to
come in we had to plan for about a week
or two to get that server just up and
running we had to do security Audits and
so it wasn't simple and anywhere along
the line any part of that chain could
break and then all of a sudden we're
slipping our deadline for publishing our
new app for weeks if not months if not
years so
thankfully
a little while later AWS came with came
up with this great idea called
ayaz information her infrastructure as a
service where they said you know what
you don't need a data center just tell
us how much horsepower you need how many
CPUs how much RAM do you need and we'll
spin up a virtual machine for you in the
cloud and this is great because now we
went from all those problems where we
had to have the physical Data Center and
we had to order in stuff and we had to
worry about supply chain issues and we
had to have physical security to now
I with a couple clicks of the mouse I
can just spin up a virtual machine in
the cloud so great we don't have to
worry about as much stuff anymore but
really we still need a big team of
Engineers right because we still it's
still just a virtual machine it's still
our responsibility we still have to
install the operating system we still
have to keep it up to date with security
patches we still have to do the
networking the routing the firewalls all
that fun stuff and so we still have the
same core engineering team but instead
of just monitoring a server here in our
data center they're monitoring that same
server in the cloud so so is a good step
in the right direction it still works
really well today but then
the concept of platform as a service
came about
um platform as a service or if you're
using AWS it's called elastic Beanstalk
is is really cool because now this takes
away the whole worry about the operating
system so now I don't have to worry
about what operating system am I running
on what version of it what are my
security patches what's my networking
what ports do I have open what ports do
I have closed uh with Paz I just tell it
that hey I want to create a web app or
maybe a web API or a website
here's my code
publish it to you AWS and then you run
it in elastic beadstock and you take
care of all that for me and the only
thing I have to do is
keep an eye on it because I'll tell it
that you know I want six CPU cores I'll
tell it that I want 32 gigs of RAM but
you know if at one point I get a whole
flood of users and all of a sudden my
server is hitting 100 I want to make
sure that scales up and then I want to
make sure that we don't use too many
resources and we're overpaying so so
pass is great because now again we don't
have to worry about the operating system
stuff anymore we have to worry about the
networking stuff all of that is
abstracted away from us so again we can
focus more on our code
but we do still have to monitor This
Server we have to make sure it stays
stays up and running we have to make
sure it scales to our users demand and
also make sure we balance that with
whatever our costs and whatever our
budgets are
but now finally we get into
serverless
so serverless takes that one step
further it takes the idea of paths the
idea of that elastic Beanstalk had and
goes one step further and says what if
you didn't even have to worry about how
many CPU cores you needed what if you
didn't have to worry about how much RAM
you needed what if you just gave me your
code
and we run it in the cloud for you
that's basically what serverless is so
with serverless
all I have to do I write my code
in Visual Studio I'll just right click
it and I'll publish it up to AWS and
then it's running it's there it's ready
uh it'll scale up as my user demands so
if I have a bunch of users I'll hit hit
the back end at the same time it'll
scale up appropriately and then if
there's no demand it'll actually scale
all the way down to zero and that's
really where we can see a lot of the
cost savings come in because if nobody's
using our app well our code's not
running in the cloud and if our code's
not doing anything in the cloud then we
don't have to pay for anything in the
cloud and so this is where I really
found that sweet spot for my back end
for my mobile apps because like I said
like I I don't make any money on these
apps so I don't have a lot of budget and
I also don't want to worry about
anything I don't want to have to be
managing servers all the time I just
want to make apps so with serverless we
can do that it abstracts away all of
those problems we can just upload our
code to the cloud and basically set it
and forget it
now let's dive a little bit deeper into
into those topics so so why why would we
want to do serverless well we're
abstracting away the servers we don't we
don't have to worry about CPU cores we
have to worry about memory all that's
taken care of for us we don't have to
worry about the operating system version
like maybe Windows just pushed out a new
security patch that's okay because AWS
is going to take care of that for us we
don't have to worry about any of that
same with networking routing DNS none of
that is our concern anymore
scaling so like I mentioned serverless
will scale to meet whatever your users
demand so if we all of a sudden get an
influx of demand because maybe some
influencer starts tweeting about our app
and we get a million downloads well
serverless can handle that as they start
hitting the back end
ews Lambda will automatically figure
that out it'll scale up appropriately
and then if all of our users go to bed
and nobody's using it at night time
it'll scale all the way back down to
zero which means we don't have to pay
any money because we're not using any
resources in the cloud anymore love that
now there is a catch
because it scales all the way down to
zero we introduce this concept called a
cold start
and a cold start happens when we have
zero instances running because our back
end's been idle but then the first user
hits our back end and what's happening
behind the scenes is you know our code
our dll file that we publish to the
cloud it's it's sitting there a user
opens our app and AWS goes oh I gotta
quickly spin up a serverless instance
and so it launches the code and quickly
spins it up and that does take some time
so here's here's the latest metrics so
on.net6
on arms on an armed CPU specifically
it'll take about a second for your
serverless instance to initialize if
it's been idle so the first user that
hits your app after it's been scaled
down to zero and it's been a little idle
we'll have about a second of cold start
time now maybe that's a lot maybe that's
a big deal maybe it's not maybe it's not
a big deal uh that kind of is the
balance we have to take into account
when we're building our apps because
this
this is really critical to serverless if
if your app always needs to have instant
response time maybe you're doing
something real time like a game or
you're dealing with monetary
transactions like stock market data and
if we wait to execute we're going to
lose money well maybe serverless isn't
the right choice maybe that's where you
you know pay a little extra for elastic
bean stock it's always up and running
it'll be responding instantly no
problems but for me as a mobile app
developer especially an Indian mobile
app developer who doesn't get paid to
make mobile apps
I was cool with this and so what I did
um if you download some of my apps from
the store when you launch them you'll
see this animated splash screen so when
the app launches I display a nice little
animation to kind of distract the user a
little bit so the user's not sitting
there going jeez why is this taking
forever to load they're just seeing this
fun little animation player and they're
oh now the app's launching and
the good side is there's also warm start
so all the way here on the right a warm
start is let's say I've just launched
the app I got the hit for the cold start
time but then you open the app when you
hit the back end you're going to hit a
warm start because that serverless
instance is already up and running so
warm start basically negligible 10
milliseconds I mean I don't I don't care
about 10 milliseconds maybe that's a big
deal to you but with warm start times we
don't really have to worry about it too
much but again with cold starts
something we want to take into account
can we work around this as that one
second penalty going to be detrimental
to our users our users even going to
notice maybe maybe not but the good news
is
every year with every iteration of.net
this cold start time gets lower or lower
so we have some numbers here from the
latest version.net.net seven
um
dot Net 7 was the first one to really
introduce this concept of native aot
which stands for ahead of time
compilation
long story short
c-sharp apps have mostly been just in
time compiled meaning the compiler is
actually running while the code's
running so that means it takes your app
a little bit longer to start up because
it's got to do a little compiling but
with ahead of time Compilation All
that's done at build time so when you
publish this app all that compilation is
already done and that allows the app to
load even faster so with Net 7 with aot
now we're seeing times getting down to
200 milliseconds and I expect this to
just continue getting lower as.net
continues to improve as aot continues to
improve as we continue to build uh
better with AWS Lambda and
integratewith.net and aot so so keep an
eye on these because
back in the day when when serverless was
New these times used to be up in the
seconds like multiple seconds and yeah
that was painful but nowadays one second
if you're still using uh net six not too
bad and then done at seven with aot
getting down into 200 300 milliseconds
now we're really getting into the point
where it's like well
maybe serverless is always applicable
maybe maybe it basically is real time we
don't have to worry about cold starts as
much
now
the benefit to all of that is this what
we call micro building
because when you use stuff in the cloud
as if you've ever if you've ever used
any cloud service adbs Lambda gcp
they bill you for what you use so if you
tell them you want to reserve a virtual
machine well they're going to give that
to you but you're going to be paying for
that virtual machine 24 7 whether you're
using it or not because they have to
carve it out and dedicate that to you
but with serverless
because it scales all the way down to
zero when you're not using it well that
means we're not getting build for
anything and so the back end costs end
up being really really cheap so these
are these are my two apps that I have in
the App Store you know Shameless plug
download them try them out give them
five stars if you like them I have an
app called get trends that helps you
monitor your GitHub repos I selfishly
made it for myself because I got a
couple hundred GitHub repos and with get
Trends I wanted a place where I could
monitor All My Views clones Stars Force
issues in one place and it'll even send
you a push notification if you get a
spike in traffic in one of your repos
which is really cool so I've had that
happen a couple times where somebody
tweets out some code that I wrote and
all of a sudden a thousand people are
looking at it and with good Trends I can
go and see how much traffic is coming in
and also where that traffic is coming
from so I can go back to that Blog owner
and shoot him a thank you for uh for
referencing my code
uh punde this is this is a fun game so
if you're into puns I teamed up with a
guy who created a website called
mondaypunday.com
and he makes these these drawings he
makes these drawings by hand and each
drawing is a pun and so for example you
might see a drawing of say a bear kind
of hunched over a pottery wheel and the
pun there is
Harry Potter
so if you're a deputants check out
pundai if you want to monitor your
GitHub repos check out get trends like I
said totally free to use and here
is my serverless costs this is legit I
just pulled these numbers last night for
my last billing cycle I've got you know
they're not huge apps couple hundred
monthly active users but
14 cents a month 14 U.S pennies
for running a back end for get trends
and then only 19 cents for pundai
that's not too bad right like I can
afford that on my my zero dollar a month
income from those apps
now
one of the coolest things and this is
one of the things I love the most about
serverless is they're all event driven
so
we've probably been talking and thinking
about mostly in terms of apis like our
app has a git API well yeah we can make
a serverless git API and that's what we
call an HTTP trigger under the hood it's
using uh aws's API Gateway but all these
other AWS Services also can trigger and
launch your serverless applications so
you can write a serverless function that
triggers anytime you add a file to S3 if
you haven't heard of S3 it's just a big
storage bucket I like to think of it as
like if you have a folder on your
desktop you can drop a text file in that
folder you can drop pictures from your
recent vacation that folder S3 is
basically just a folder in the cloud so
you can put files in it and you can have
a serverless function that triggers
anytime a new file is added so let's say
somebody's added a text file you can
immediately have your code trigger to
say parse and analyze that text file
maybe you're doing some machine learning
on it or something like that likewise
like database triggers so let's say you
have an app where when you add a new
user we add a new row to the user
database and
we can have dynamodb trigger right away
to do a couple things in the background
because you know what's what's the worst
thing in the world right like when
you're a new user to the app you already
have to make your accounts you got to
use your email address create a new
password great and then once you're done
with that like you just want to use the
app you don't want to sit there and wait
for everything to get verified so what
we can do is application developers is
we could use something like a dynamodb
trigger a database trigger to fire off
this stuff in the background so we can
verify their information while they're
in the app and using it and then we can
just send them a welcome email and they
don't have to sit around and you know
feel like the app's taking forever to
get onboarded so you get all these
different types of triggers there's even
more than this so highly highly
recommend checking these out because
this is where we start getting into the
concept of microservices so with micro
Services you can start to see how you
could have multiple serverless functions
and keep in mind a serverless function
is based basically just a method it's
just one thing it's just one uh just a
couple lines of code it should only take
a couple seconds to execute a couple
minutes to execute it the most in fact
if it takes too long to execute Lambda
will actually kick you out it'll
actually turn off your serverless
instance and scale it back down to zero
because if you need 15 minutes to do
something well
you you probably shouldn't be using
microservices but we can have all these
event driven microservices that all fire
asynchronously asynchronously they all
scale up and down as needed it's really
really good stuff and this is what I
want to get into to show you guys today
so
I I brought a an end-to-end demo that
we're gonna
show off and dig into the code see how
all this works and
this is what we're doing now
you may or may not know it but a really
common scenario in mobile applications
is anytime you upload an image
what they're doing they take that image
and they down scale it because
phones are super powerful nowadays so
like the new iPhone 14 I think it takes
48 megapixel photos so if you upload a
48 megapixel photo to say Instagram
if Instagram then serves that same 48
megapixel photo to all of us that means
anytime you go look at my profile it
would take forever to load because you'd
see one picture load after a couple
seconds and then the next 48 megapixel
photo would load after a couple seconds
so what companies do like Instagram they
immediately take that photo and scale it
so they'll they'll scale it down to a
point where it still looks good on
certain devices like they'll scale it
specifically from mobile they'll scale
it specifically for web for desktop
and that's what we see when we launch
our app so what I've made here is
basically that workflow I've created a
mobile app using.net Maui and c-sharp
that takes our picture then we upload
that picture to a HTTP trigger a post
API that post API is going to ingest the
photo that I upload stored in our S3
storage bucket and then once that
happens we'll have an S3 trigger kick
off automatically
and that S3 trigger is called generate
thumbnail because it takes that photo
that we uploaded and I scale it way down
to just 200 by 200 pixels
put that back in the bucket and then
we've also added in a get API down here
called get thumbnail which is also an
HTTP picker HTTP trigger so so let's
check this out so I've got um
I've got the app running here behind me
behind the slides and it's it's made in
down at Maui with if you haven't heard
it down to Maui before it allows you to
make mobile apps for IOS and Android and
c-sharp but you can also make desktop
apps as well so Mac OS and windows so
here I have my Android emulator I'm
going to click upload photo
we should see me come up in just a
second oh
maybe maybe not well I'll tell you what
let's
click the take picture button
oh
well there's me dry around here before I
came here
[Laughter]
I'll tell you what let's uh
pull it up on Mac
looks like this Android emulators going
through some problems here
all right so let's launch it here on the
Mac
because we can do that since dotnet Maui
allows us to make Mac OS apps as well
and c-sharp
there we go
all right so we'll take
take a picture
Maybe
ah what happened
I wonder if my
I wonder if the screen sharing is
getting away the camera
oh okay looks like we might have a
picture here on Android
come on let's see upload something okay
cool
so if we uploaded this weird picture
that must have been saved in the cache
somewhere and so right now it's
uploading that picture so it's
uh no do we lose internet access to uh
we're falling apart here guys uh let's
see
are we
let's try restarting the emulator real
quick let's make sure we can
ping out to Google that's working
give it one more shot
if not you can just take my word I swear
it works
yeah all but something with the AV
systems uh get in the way but
shoot well
oh wow look at that
so it should be using my Mac OS camera
to look at me right now but I tell you
what well I'll leave this running
foreign
probably would have dressed up if I knew
these pictures would show up
but uh but let's let's take a look at
the code so
so what's going on here we've got
we've got our mobile app and the first
thing it's going to do is upload that
image uh to a post API that we've made
using AWS Lambda
and so
let's look at
that post API
oh maybe
we'll keep poking the Android emulator
maybe that'll work but uh where are we
so here we go so we have our
our upload image
across our fingers well that's well
that's spinning his wheels
um
all right so here is the first
serverless function that we're going to
look at today so this one is called
upload image and it's a post API hey oh
look at that
so
for whatever reason this was me taking
pictures like 12 hours ago but you can
see so Android's actually stretching out
the picture if I zoom in here you know
if you look along maybe my hairline here
you can see a little bit more detail
than over here where everything gets
really blurry because now this is only
200 by 200 pixels so again what just
happened was we uploaded that photo
and it was immediately dropped into the
storage bucket this S3 trigger kicked
off automatically created our thumbnail
for us put it back in the bucket and now
the phone's able to request the new
thumbnail picture from our get thumbnail
API
so looking at the code here
this is our upload image API and you'll
notice you'll notice a trend as we kind
of go through all these the first thing
we have up here is I'm initializing an
Amazon S3 client this is really cool
because this S3 client well hey it's
it's free this is just included in the
in the s3.net SDK in the nuget package
but when I say new Amazon S3 client when
this code is running in the cloud
because
it my functions running in the cloud and
I'm already
inside and it knows who I am this S3
client also has all my credentials as
well so with that S3 storage bucket it
is completely locked down if I gave you
the direct URL to the image that we just
created you wouldn't be able to access
it
very very secure completely locked down
but since we're already in the cloud and
and abs Lambda knows all my credentials
and they know what resources I can
access when I just say new s new Amazon
S3 client
that gets included as well so I don't
have to worry about managing security
keys or credentials I don't have to use
any environment variables I don't have
to store any secrets to worry about
accidentally committing them in GitHub
because
new Amazon S3 client takes care of that
for me now
the serverless function is really right
here it's this one method called
function Handler and this method accepts
a API Gateway HTTP API V2 proxy proxy
request that's a lot of words just to
say this is the HTTP request that just
came in
um it is using aws's API gateways so
that's why they add in some of that and
it is using HTTP 2 so that's why I get
HTTP API view too but for all intents
and purposes this is just the HTTP
request so this is where we can check
you know the the query parameters that
come in this is where we can uh it's a
post API so we can get the data from the
body
so what I've done here is kind of like
how we would design any API right I
first checked the query parameters
because the way I've designed it I have
the mobile app include the file name as
the query a query string so if that
query string isn't missing I don't know
what the file name is so I immediately
tell you sorry bad request you're
missing my query parameters but if it's
a good request
then we can start parsing that image so
we we parse the data I get the image and
then I have this method that I created
called upload content to S3 and if we
dig into this
so this uses that same S3 client that
we're just talking about which is again
logged in it's got all my credentials
just baked into that SDK by default and
so the other parameters this takes is a
string for the name of the bucket so
your S3 bucket has a name and the string
called key well that's just the file
name so the what you're going to name
the file where you put in the bucket and
then I made a generic so it can accept
any type of content and then also you
know we want to have our Lambda logger
in here so we can write to the logs just
in case
so what I do I first look to see is that
content a stream which in this case it
is we're uploading our image as as a
memory stream and if that's the case
what we're doing we're creating a put
object request this put object request
also is given to us for free thanks to
the AWS S3 SDK and so if we have a
stream we add that content as an input
stream but if it's anything else we can
just serialize that
and put it in the content body of our
object request and then really all we
have to do is say s3client dot put
object async so once we do that we get a
response back that lets us know
hopefully that everything worked out
everything worked out okay
and the upload succeeded now the only
thing I do this is which is a little bit
extra is remember how I said our S3
buckets are just completely locked down
like if I was if I was on AWS right now
and I could pull up the URL for that
file and give it to everybody in this
room nobody would be asked be able to
access it because you don't have the
credentials and including me I would
have to give myself credentials uh to
use that URL but what we can do we can
generate a pre-signed URL where I tell
it create a URL for this specific bucket
the specific key which is again the file
name and that'll last for in this case
one minute
and then that URL is what I can send
back to my mobile user and now I give
them a little bit of access into the S3
bucket but only for a minute but that's
plenty of time for them to receive the
URL and display the image on their
device
this is also very similar
um I don't know exactly how uh or uh how
Instagram does it but they also have uh
they generate pre-signed URLs as well so
if you ever try to
look at an image on Instagram and then a
couple days later go back to the same
URL it won't work because it has to be a
pre-signed URL to give you access so
sorry so we've uploaded that content to
S3 here in our upload image function and
then we've got the photo Ur URI and in
that case we can just return a response
back to our user so this is a API
Gateway HTTP 2 API VC proxy response uh
wherever you tell it that the status
code is okay and then what I do I just
serialize that photo URI and send it
back to the mobile app so they can
display that image on the device
cool
so we've successfully
uploaded the photo
that function is added it to our S3
bucket and now what's going to happen is
our S3 trigger is going to automatically
kick off so if we look at our code again
I've got a
a function here called generate
thumbnail and
looks kind of similar right like I mean
it's called generate thumbnail but we're
still creating a new S3 client and we
still have this method called function
Handler but the difference here is we
don't have that API Gateway V2 request
we have an S3 event because S3 is
triggering this serverless function
so
what this code does we make sure that
the the file exists that you know
nothing weird happened it's not null and
then I do a double check here to make
sure that the file name doesn't end with
thumbnail because
when I generate the thumbnail I take the
same file name and then I just append
underscore thumbnail.png so
after I create that thumbnail I have to
put it back in the bucket but then that
would trigger this S3 bucket again so
this is how I can just make sure like
okay if you're already a thumbnail or
we're just going to return we're not
going to do anything with you
and then down here
pretty similar we're going to tell our
S3 client to get us that object so we
pass in all the info that we just got
from our S3 event up here
and it gives us our bucket name it gives
us the name of the file the key that was
added
so we get that response back of course
we've got to make sure it's good
otherwise we can't move forward but
once we have it then we can copy that
response stream into an image and we can
start manipulating it so down here I
have a method called get PNG thumbnail
where I'm using a cool Library called
image sharp that does all this image
resizing options for me which is great
because I had no idea how to do it I
basically just copy pasted this code
from the image sharp library and Happy
Days look at that I can just tell it to
resize to a 200 by 200 pixel image tell
that image to mutate specifically to
resize it
then we save that PNG to our new memory
stream and then we can return that back
above
to use it elsewhere now the only other
thing I need to do is generate that new
thumbnail name and like I mentioned I
just use that same file name that the
mobile app gives me and I just remove
the extension
and add in that suffix that we saw
earlier that underscore thumbnail.png so
now I know this is the same file but
it's my thumbnail version of it
and now that I have my image here my
thumbnail I had named it well now I can
upload that content to S3 so I wrote
this this method that
we just saw earlier right this is uh the
same same method so we're just passing
in that content we're putting it in here
as a stream or or serializing it to the
content body
Happy Days generate that pre-signed URL
and we're good to go so
so this kicked off automatically
once we added that first image to the
bucket it generated our thumbnail and
then we uploaded that image back or the
New Image the new thumbnail back into S3
storage
all right
so the only one we haven't looked at yet
is this get thumbnail
and this is a get API so
pretty similar to The Post API that we
looked at it's
it's still just a function Handler we're
still taking in an API Gateway HTTP 2
API V2 for actually request
um
and the only difference this time is
we're not ingesting a photo we're just
going to give you the thumbnail for the
image you're looking for because you
know the mobile device only knows the
file name that it gave us so it maybe
uploaded the file called brandon.png and
so when it goes to load that file it's
going to say hey give me the thumbnail
for Brandon it doesn't know that I
renamed that file and I've done a bunch
of processing to it so so again it gives
me that file name as a query parameter
assuming that's there then we can move
on if not we'll tell it's a bad request
but what I do is I say okay well what is
the file name you gave me and I'll run
that same code to generate the thumbnail
file name from that
and then I'll call this
s3service.get file URI method here where
what we do is if you don't give me an
expiration date I'll automatically make
sure that this URL expires in a minute
but yeah basically we're just making
sure the file exists and then we're
generating that pre-signed URL like we
talked about earlier and returning that
URL back
here
there we go as our thumbnail URL and
that's it and then this git API is
basically done it's got the thumbnail
URL it makes sure it's not null because
if it is null then we're going to say
Hey you told me to look for this file
and I couldn't find it so 404 not found
but if we can then we'll serialize that
thumbnail URL send it back to the device
so now it can display that image to the
user on the screen
foreign all right so some pretty cool
stuff again super powerful because all
of this will scale independently so if
all of a sudden we have users uploading
photos like crazy well
Lambda will scale up accordingly and if
all of a sudden we have S3 storage is
just an undulated with new new files
then our our S3 trigger over there we'll
scale up accordingly and it's all
running asynchronously so users don't
have to wait they have to worry about
process times they don't have to just
see a spinning wheel on their mobile
device because there's nothing worse
than just staring at a device that just
says loading loading loading so
okay so that's how or that's an example
of how we can build a a serverless
architecture for our back end but this
is an intro intro class right like how
do we even create these like where did I
even come up with this code how do I
know about uh that API Gateway V2 proxy
response well what
I highly highly recommend
is when you're starting out
you're going to want to install this AWS
toolkit so there's a extension for
visual studio there's extension for
visual studio code as well called AWS
toolkit and that'll come with all the
templates that you need for creating
I'll say just about anything in AWS
we'll just be focusing on serverless
stuff today but then it also adds in a
bunch of hooks into visual studio so
that when you're done with your code you
can basically just right click on your
code and say yeah publish this to AWS
done
so
highly recommend the AWS toolkit if
you're more of a command line developer
they do have a net command line
extension that you can install so if you
prefer to say net new uh AWS Lambda
something something you can do that as
well but
to keep it nice and simple and also
because I like this because I'm lazy
we're going to stay in Visual Studio
here and check out this AWS toolkit so
so after you've installed the the
toolkit
the next time you go to spin up a new
project
we can just filter for Lambda
and we can tell we want to create a
new AWS Lambda sure AWS Lambda 6. why
not and then once we've done that
we get all these options so these are
all the templates so things like you
know we saw our S3 function just a
minute ago or if you want to do
something with Kinesis which uses
streaming data maybe you want to ingest
video streams and you can do all sorts
of crazy things so let's just tell we
want a an S3 function
and let's see if I can
find the OK button
it's hidden down here
or maybe
let's see if we can just change the
display a little bit
need more pixels there we go
let's do one a little bit better
go
ah much nicer so there's our finish
button okay so this will create a an S3
function for us
and when I open this up it's probably
going to look and feel pretty similar
let's see
zoomed out a little too far maybe a
little bit more how about
125 why not so so pretty similar to the
code we already looked at this gives us
a
a class
it gives us
a method here called function Handler
that takes in the S3 event just like we
had for our S3 trigger that generated
the thumbnail and that's that's it
because again remember serverless
functions
should basically just be a method think
of it as
well it is it's called a function right
so it's just one function it's going to
do something real quick it's going to
get in get out so
so here is that function Handler in the
template
we see that it takes in an S3 event and
now we can start writing our code and
then whenever we're done
back in our solution Explorer we can
just right click here
and now we have this option that says
publish to Lambda so
super super easy you just say I want to
publish this to AWS Lambda we give it a
name like NDC S3 demo and I think
there's one more thing I have to give it
like user permissions
there we go it's yeah well yeah given an
IAM role and then once we click upload
our functions now up and running in the
cloud so
highly highly recommend that AWS toolkit
because it just makes stuff like this
super super easy
now there's one more thing I want to
show you because
I'll bet a lot of us in here have
existing apis already
well there's something really cool that
we can do with with Lambda so let's uh
let's spin up a new project so let's say
we want a web API
in your case you would just use your
existing web API but I need to slap one
into this project to show this off
so we've got our standard asp.net core
web API you know if you ever build one
you're probably familiar with this
template with a weather forecast
controller it's got this get method here
so we're not changing any of this code
but what we are going to do
we want to publish this to a serverless
function so I'm going to add a nuget
package
and I'm going to add in
amazon.lamda.aspnet.hosting or actually
asp.net core server.hosting
and pop that into our existing web API
and then all we have to do to get this
existing web API to run on Lambda
Builder
services
at AWS and we'll tell it it's a HTTP API
that's it and so now we could publish
this uh web API that we've had for years
and it'll just run on Lambda uh super
super cool super super simple and the
best part is
this line of code when you run it
locally
does nothing so you can still debug
locally you can still use it like you
would unit test it put break points in
this doesn't change anything it'll still
run on Kestrel nothing changes it's only
only ever used if it detects your
applications actually running on AWS
Lambda now there is one gotcha here so
yes yes just one line of code but
if we go back to our solution Explorer
here and I right click on this web API
you'll notice I don't have a published
to Lambda option here I've published the
AWS which is this is a little different
so let's see what's going on here well
if we look at this it thinks that I want
to publish to elastic beadstock which is
great nothing nothing against elastic
Beanstalk if you want to use it go for
it but we're talking about serverless
here and there's no option here for
serverless so what we have to do is we
have to help out the AWS toolkit just a
little bit so if we if we go back into
our Lambda c-sharp project there's a
line in here that says AWS project type
so if we just grab this line of code
here
bring that into our CS project file for
our existing web API
now the AWS toolkit goes uh okay you
don't want elastic Beanstalk you want
Lambda and now when I right click
there we go now we can publish it back
up to AWS just like we wanted to
cool
so
so lots and lots of really cool things
highly recommend jumping into the
toolkit playing around with it uh
and I want to give you a one more chance
here if you haven't already make sure to
take out your phones grab a picture of
this link because this is where you can
find information about everything we
talked about today so the slides are
here available for you we have I'll
include the video to this presentation
once it gets posted up to YouTube I've
got links to the AWS toolkit for visual
studio Visual Studio code and so
everything you need to get started you
can find here at codetraveler.io NDC
Dash Lambda Dash intro
thank you
[Applause]
so looks like we have a little bit time
left oh no you can go that's fine I was
just gonna say if anybody wants to come
up and ask any questions
um I mean it looks like we have a
microphone so yeah I want we start a
queue I'll uh I'll give you the caveat
that I'm pretty new to AWS Lambda myself
so don't ask me do anything too
difficult but maybe we can all figure it
out together uh do you want to come up
first
or or shout it out I can repeat it
Ah that's a good question so yeah it's
like what if what if our web API is huge
right
um so it would all exist under the same
Lambda instance and so if it's too big
we probably would want to break it up
because let's say
let's say you got 20 apis and two of
them get used all the time and the other
18 don't well every time your app
launches it's gonna have to spin up all
that code so what would probably be
better is yeah break those up
individually
and then you can have those certain
Lambda functions that get called all the
time
and then you don't have to necessarily
worry about
it's like unnecessary charges and using
too much because uh yeah I could see
with the scaling if folks start hitting
all the different apis that it could
start kind of going a little walking to
the scaling so yeah I would probably
chop that up a little bit which
hopefully isn't too difficult for you
but yeah good question
go yes please
has its own application proxy in front
of it
in front of the Lambda Lambda running
right
I'm not getting it wrong probably but
it's AWS Lambda runs application proxy
in front of it
um so the security you have set up will
will still be the same so like if you
need authentication cookies and headers
that'll that'll still be the same is
that what you're asking
um or will there be a set of
configurations that we do
need to be yeah I'll tell you this I I
don't know but yeah I assume you'd have
to do some extra configuration to get
um especially if if it's external
authentication to get that set up
because because yeah when when you push
the stuff to the cloud they kind of lock
everything down by default so I'd assume
you'd have to give access to anything
external coming in but
this is
um I'm not sure I haven't gotten that
deep into it but good question does
anybody know um
right on thank you
[Laughter]
yes
right
absolutely
um so yeah I was super lazy when I
created this uh S3 trigger I just said
fire on any any new file and yeah I I
knew for my demo would be fine but yeah
what you can do you can file or you can
filter on
um file type folder so you can have
multiple folders in your S3 bucket and
only fire this if it's uh triggered by a
file added this specific folder or only
fire if it's a PNG file so yeah you
would and you would definitely want to
do that that's a really good point
because yeah otherwise you're waking up
this serverless instance to just do
nothing and go back to sleep
good good point
um I've only done it in the S3 console
um does anyone know if you could do that
config and code
there we go
any other questions that
you can help me solve
thank you by the way
sure having a normal web API after and
you know make a modification and publish
it to a Lambda
but that's something that seems a bit
strange to me that doesn't seem to be
something that I'm aware that Azure can
do so how somehow Amazon a better
hosting Microsoft products now than
Microsoft I haven't missed something
um no comment
uh yeah I'm also not aware that Azure
can do that as either
can they yeah cool
can you run containers uh yep absolutely
um I probably didn't scroll down far
enough yeah in that template when you
say file new project you can put you can
specify like a Net 7 container
containerized app so yeah totally uh
I I personally stay away from containers
because I'm just a mobile app developer
those those scare me
awesome well thanks everyone
right but it was almost double without
yep
is it just because that's now abandoned
you just lost it like that and so
Microsoft don't care anymore or no
um so so a T's got aots got its pros and
cons so
um in order to uh compile everything
ahead of time obviously your compiler is
going to take a little bit longer but
your file size is going to be bigger too
because
what's going to happen is it has to
compile down all those Base Class
libraries that we're using so your your
file size gets a little bit bigger and
then there's a little bit of a concern
and kind of why Microsoft's not pushing
aot too hard right now is
they they do something called a
it's called tree shaking where they they
try not to bring in the entire.net
library and compile it they try to just
figure out what you're doing but if
you're using generics like
um I'm doing a little bit in the app uh
a generic could be anything right so it
kind of has to bring in olive.net so
so your file size is going to be a
little bit bigger with aot obviously the
compiler is going to take a little bit
longer but yeah that's not a big deal
the only concern I would have right now
with aot is you know test it test it
test it because maybe it removed a file
or didn't compile file that you need
um the but yeah basically what it's
doing is just
essentially everything the server would
do when it launches your file like just
in general not even you know ignoring
Lambda ignoring serverless aots
basically just doing what a server would
do when you say run ahead of time so
yeah and apparently you get much much
faster time so that's something I'm
really excited about but I'll probably
wait till like.net 8 until I really
really trust it but yeah it's a really
cool technology
all right great well thanks everybody
thanks so much for coming